I hate intro shokugeki no souma season 3
part to read kick things off with an
announcement from the first seat Tsukasa
saying that the advancement exams for
the first years are coming up as ami had
changed the exam that was originally
designed to weed out even more students
from the Academy to one that is easily
passed as long as you stick to the
central curriculum so basically the test
is designed to weed out anybody who is
rebelling against the teachings of
central and as ami meanwhile Adina who
is still staying at Polar Star dormitory
sneaks up to sohma's room oh yeah here
we go the daddy is she's mixed with Joey
two toes long khanh wingman tactics I
know exactly where this is going but I
was wrong in the end of just talking
instead we get a flashback of how a diva
had met Joey cheeto who was cooking for
son Zaman in secret and a Deena happened
to find them of course Joey cheeto being
the overlooked gem of the show is too
nice to leave her out so he whips her up
a quick meal she falls in love with his
cooking and his carefree approach while
making his dish and that's what inspired
her to pursue cooking more seriously
Zuma decides that he meets to invoke
that motivation again and begins to cook
her a meal
she's obviously skeptical at first but
he makes his own version of a tempura
Bowl and after tasting it she is
reminded of how she felt after tasting
Joey Trudeau's cooking that day the next
day she gathers everybody together with
a newfound determination and vows to
help them pass the advancement exams
episode 2 for the advancement exams the
students will start in South Hokkaido
and make their way north as they clear
each stage over the next week everybody
at Polar Star along with the aldini
brothers Andy Kumi our top by Eddy know
what they need to know to pass the exams
as you can see the daddy issues are
starting to bubble up and reflect on her
wardrobe and that's good for someone
because that's another future role play
opportunity for the first exam some was
put in a group with alice ryo yuki and
as always mega me if anybody in the
group fails then they all fail so it's
obvious that all the rebels are being
grouped together to make it easier to
knock him out for their first task they
have to prepare a salmon dish and wall
the other students receive fresh salmon
all the rebels are given the lowest
quality salmon luckily some of the stuff
that Edina had taught them through the
week
prepare them to deal with this curveball
and none of the rebels are expelled in
the first round
well traveling to the next location
Edina is visited by some of the
PolarStar members and we find out that
she's starting to enjoy spending time
with them
Zuma also comes by and while talking
with him under the starry sky eddie mair
realizes that he doesn't annoy her like
he used to
uh ya see the way she's staring at him
get that teachers outfit ready yep so
three everyone arrives at the second
location and again they are split into
groups this time they are tasked with
making a noodle dish but central makes
it so the rebels can't get any quality
ingredients Zuma who is with mega me and
talk to me think about how they can
scrape together something to make a
noodle dish they come across the
potatoes and again thanks to the lessons
from Eddie that they whip up some go
sets ooh ooh Don allowing the rebels to
pass on to the third stage however for
the third stage everybody is split up
and sent to different locations
Central's getting tired of their
persistence so they decide that in order
to pass the third stage the rebels are
gonna have to cook against the Elite ten
Zuma ends up with Eddie nine megami
where he finds out that he's gonna be
going up against the newest Elite 10
member hi Yama hi Yama entered a battle
royale to earn himself the ninth see
after each kakuka and mega Shima were
removed yep so for gideon makes his
reappearance when he tells soma and hai
yama that they're gonna be working with
Bera me for their cook-off
well testing for ideas soma learns that
bury me is hard to cook because of the
intense gamey flavor the previous
eight-seat Kouga comes to see soma and
help him with his dish they both go out
to observe the habitat of the Bears
where soma gets the idea to use
schisandra berries to control the gamy
taste after they test the few dishes
there's an improvement in taste but hai
yama drops by and reveals that he's
gonna be using cajun spices for his dish
after smelling that soma is planning on
using schisandra berries he seems rather
confident that he's gonna win episode 5
we learned that hai Yama is being forced
by a zombie to join the elite 10 and
take part in the cook-off if he doesn't
do this Jun will lose funding for their
research society and it'll be shut down
Zuma isn't happy about hearing how hai
Yama caved so easily to central he goes
and finds hai Yama and explains that
he's gonna be going all-out and he
expects hi Yama to do the same
yeah the rebels are getting their
matches with the Elite ten underway as
well we stay focused on sohma's match
though
we're not gonna say who is Alice's
father shows up to be the judge helping
him our two girls named Bertha and
cheetah the cooking gets underway with
both so my aunt uyama taking a fried
bear meat approach with soma finishing
first suma makes a fried bear meat
cutlet while using the smelliest but
also the tastiest part in the last scene
hi Yama gets ready to reveal his dish
next episode six the judges taste hi
Yama's dish and come to the immediate
conclusion that so much dish just can't
compare oh no he's gonna be expelled ha
just kidding they now have to taste the
dishes with sauces on the side don't
know why they want to do that in the
first place but of course soma pulls
ahead in a 2-1 victory hey Yama realizes
that he was tunnel-visioned on
protecting Jun and his research society
so he forgot how much he enjoyed cooking
with everybody
later on soma offers that hi Yama and
Jun come to stay a PolarStar dormitory
as well now that they lost their
Research Society and don't have a place
to stay they appreciate the offer but hi
Yama knows that he's gonna be expelled
so that's not gonna be possible but he
isn't the only one facing expulsion all
of the other rebels that went up against
the Elite ten had lost so they're on the
chopping block - episode 7 Nero had made
her test really easy so Megami and taka
me are able to pass leaving just them
along with soma and Adina as the last
rebels remaining suma comes to the
conclusion that the only way to resend
the expulsion is to take over the elite
10 council the only problem is that
there's no reason for as ami or central
to accept shokugeki challenges with the
seats on the line that is until Joey
judo and Sun zaman show up out of
nowhere joy kudo proposes a team
shokugeki where the rebels will go up
against the elite ten and if the rebels
lose joy kudo will shut down his diner
and join central this is too good for a
zombie to pass up so he agrees to it we
have a mini competition where Joey judo
and gain trained the students in a 3v3
competition where the students support
them as they cook while not being able
to talk episode 8 booth teams catch on
to what their leader is doing and manage
to finish their dishes this is really
just filler content they compare the two
dishes in a hands up being a draw after
a short trip the elite ten and the
rebels meet up to finalize the rules of
the shokugeki they make
clear that if the rebels win they get
the Elite ten seats ultimately
dismantling a zombies overall goals and
of the UE 10 when the rebels will be
expelled I enjoy Trudeau will join
central Kazami tries to force Eddy med
to cook for the elite n side since she's
technically still the tenth seat she
refuses and finally stands up to her dad
while resigning as the tenth C in order
to fight for the rebels II episode 9
this episode is a giant flashback of
everything that happened to Joey judo
while he was a student he was considered
a genius claiming a seat in the elite 10
in his first year at the academy not
only that but he also makes quite a name
for himself when he takes part in a team
shokugeki all alone against 50 opponents
defeating them all and earning himself
the title of demon once they got to
their third year game became the first
seat Joey cheeto the second seat and as
ami was the third seat although gain was
only the first seat because Joey cheeto
wasn't the best student often showing up
late to class if at all but in terms of
cooking joy cheeto always had the upper
hand with the two of them having 121
shokugeki Kees joy Trudeau had won a
hundred of them so he was always the
unofficial first seat all of his success
begins to weigh on him with expectations
getting higher and higher until
eventually he loses his passion for
cooking soon Zaman had realized what was
happening and tells him that he needs to
leave Japan and cooking for a while
because he can't keep going like this
Joey judo finds his passion again after
soma is born
and that's when he comes back to cooking
episode 10 as everybody arrives at the
location for the shokugeki and things
start to get underway the rebels get
some last-minute additions the former HC
cougar at the former 7c ishke the former
third seat McGee SEMA and the current
professional stalker Subaru joined their
ranks to fight in the shokugeki making
it an eight verse eight it's decided
that the matches will be done in three
1v1 s at a time the first three are soma
going up against the 6th see Nene easkey
going up against the new hcg Tatsu Judeo
and Miggy Shima going up against the new
5th seed cavenaghi Shoko Zuma has some
bad luck when he draw soba as his dish
which just so happens to be named a
specialty and the last scene Judeo
insults PolarStar members upon hearing
this we see a new side of hg who decides
that he's actually gonna cook seriously
Hetal see that's good Costel Madoka
episode 11 really get a little backstory
on each key and name a who have actually
known each other ever since they were
kids the rest of the episode focuses on
each keys match where Judeo finishes his
eel dish first which does pretty well
with the judges who she on the other
hand made a hit to mabushii dish while
using ingredients that he got from Polar
Star members this dish easily defeats
Studios dish and afterwards he forces
Judeo to apologize for insulting the
others back to the hole each key and
name a thing we get a short flashback of
when they were kids and find out why
name a never liked ishke she resented
how easily he picked up skills that took
her years to learn including cooking she
makes her frustrations known to him and
wants to challenge him in the future
rounds in response to this HG tries to
explain to her that she's up against the
protagonist in the first round so she's
obviously not gonna win episode well
many presents her cocky I guess a CUDA
shrimp tempura and it's received well by
the judges Zuma fires back with his
instant yakisoba dish invoking the
sacred foodgasm instant noodles was one
of sohmas favorite dishes to make while
growing up so it's safe to say that he's
had a lot of practice this ultimately
gives him the upper hand in the bow and
he goes on to win giving the rebels
their second victory Rikishi meal also
wins his matches well but we only get a
glimpse of that and with his victory the
first round is a complete sweep for the
rebels with higher seats still waiting
for their chance and less important side
characters to match them I have a
feeling that there are still a lot of
matches left in this competition you can
find those matches in the future season
and that'll be in the bottom up door
whatever I'm finish with day or you can
check out all the shokugeki recaps in
this playlist here you can also find the
links in the description below and the
only thing I hate more than intros is
outros